[Musica]
Buonasera pubblico Così non facciamo
errori di
genere Are you
ready are you
ready No perché io a quest'ora sono già
a letto normalmente quindi sto facendo
uno sforzo incredibile bene
concentriamoci
Allora è da tantissimi anni che ogni
estate vado in vacanza in Sardegna come
tanti e vado sempre nello stesso posto
un posto bellissimo che non conosce
nessuno però solo i
sardi e nella casa dove vado appunto da
tutti questi anni ho sempre trovato due
Punti Fermi Sapete quelle cose che
quando ti cade tutto nella vita cambia
tutto due certezze un albero di nespole
e
paquita la cagnolina dei vicini una
salsiccetta bianc e nera proprio
bellissima dolcissima
eh proprio affettuosa carinissima con
ste orecchie lunghissime che sono più
grandi di lei una grande accompagnatrice
di passeggiate all'alba sai quante ne
abbiamo fatte in questi anni quindi due
punti fermi mai
cambiate ci salutavamo Ciao bene ci
vediamo L'estate prossima Ecco
quest'anno non è andata così quest'anno
non li ho ritrovati nessuno dei
due la l'ondata di calore che ha colpito
la Sardegna a fine luglio raggiunto
anche
50° li ha fatti
fuori l'albero seccato Marrone Cioè una
cosa tristissima a vedersi e pakita era
anzianotta non ha tenuto l'han trovata
tutta disidratata e in 24 ore suo organi
hanno ceduto per l'altro uno strazio
perché io sono arrivata il giorno dopo
Insomma
bruttissimo
Ecco questa Voi direte Ma è un cane un
albero cè
Cosa ne dici di tutte quelle persone che
per ondate di calore muoiono sempre di
più anziani vulnerabili persone che non
non hanno i mezzi per
raffrescare solo in emilia-romagna nel
2022 sono morte per calore più del 20%
cioè scusate 20% in più se poi usciamo
dai confini regionali andiamo in quelli
nazionali andiamo in quelli europei
andiamo in quelli
globali cioè le cifre volano e le cifre
vanno alle stelle se poi pensiamo ad
altri disastri ecologici come appunto le
inondazioni ne abbiamo fatto un piccolo
assaggino noi ma poi basta aprire la TV
accendere la TV e Ecco se ne vedono di
tutti i
colori un
vuoto per me questa anche se piccola è
stata una sberla perché mi ha ricordato
tutto questo ma mi ha anche ricordato
che altro che next generation
generazioni future mia nonna qua i
cambiamenti climatici stanno facendo
fuori persone animali natura adesso
quindi è stata una sberla Anzi un
mattone in più di consapevolezza che noi
con l'azione umana stiamo esagerando
Abbiamo esagerato e quindi con l'azione
umana dobbiamo cambiare dobbiamo agire e
dobbiamo agire Possiamo e dobbiamo agire
anche da qui dalla nostra piccola grande
Bologna ed è per questo in questo senso
che stasera ho voluto accettare l'invito
di Andrea a questo tedex per raccontarvi
di un viaggio un viaggio che la città di
Bologna è iniziato Circa un anno fa e
sul quale vorrei coinvolgervi nel quale
vorrei coinvolgervi tutti e
tutte un viaggio molto importante che
faremo che stiamo facendo insieme ad
altre 99 città in
Europa sostenuti dalla Commissione
Europea che ci ha affidato questa
missione quella di raggiungere La
neutralità climatica al
2030 ovvero quello di pareggiare le
emissioni Che buttiamo in
atmosfera con quelle che l'atmosfera può
assorbire In poche parole Noi entro il
2030 a partire dal 2018 abbiamo questo
tempo
per ridurre dell' 80% le emissioni di
gas climalteranti che sono quelle che
fanno incazzare il clima No Appunto e
creano
disastri in tutta la
città Dobbiamo abbassare ridurre le
emissioni negli edifici perché il
70% delle emissioni viene soprattutto
dagli edifici come li riscaldiamo come
li
raffrescare e quindi ecco è un'impresa
molto complessa molto difficile
un'impresa eccezionale se possiamo
chiamarla così e forse perché io sono
nata negli anni 60
questo paragone mi mi suona mi ricorda
le missioni spaziali no negli anni 60
appunto che federavo in America tutti la
finanza l'economia la politica la
ricerca l'innovazione la società la
gente la gente davanti allo schermo a me
Io mi ricordo è nel mio immaginario
questa cosa no che che Amstrong andava
sulla luna ecco Io vorrei che anche noi
portassimo Bologna sulla luna e che
facessimo un viaggio insieme come città
per cambiare le cose secondo me è la è
l'ultima chance che abbiamo di fare
questa cosa di fare questo viaggio
e nella mia vita io ho sempre vissuto il
fatto che molto spesso il viaggio è più
importante della metà stessa perché nel
viaggio si capiscono tante cose si
cresce si trovano le contraddizioni le
complessità si snocciolano i conflitti
Si si fronteggiano in maniera diversa e
se c'è una cosa al giorno d'oggi che è
piena di complessità di contraddizioni
di conflitti Questa è la gestione della
crisi climatica i nostri giornali qui a
Bologna Cioè li leggete Ed è pieno di
questo ok E quindi cosa sarà questo
viaggio questo vi viagio sarà un viaggio
fatto di tante cose di tante persone di
tanti enti Ma avrà un motore questo
motore sarà il contratto climatico
cittadino in inglese lo chiamano climate
City Contract C sempre più facile
l'inglese No noi abbiamo City c'è tutto
dentro italiano il contratto climatico
della città per la città nella città con
la città sulla città Insomma un
contratto climatico bolognese bulgnais
facciamolo anche con coso locale un po'
di di Flavor locale quindi un contratto
che possa federare tutti i grandi i
piccoli il pubblico il
privato i grossi Player che possono che
sono in grado di avere un impatto
diretto in termini di riduzione delle
emissioni anche di produzione di energia
pulita per esempio sto pensando a
livello pubblico al Comune di Bologna il
Comune di Bologna sta facendo varie cose
stiamo mettendo il tram stiamo
sostenendo la incentivando la le la la
bicicletta con le piste ciclabili e
quant'altro stiamo diminuendo stiamo
cercando di diminuire la velocità Eh non
tirate i pomodori perché io ci credo
molto a questa a questa scelta stiamo
promuovendo l'economia circolare e
l'utilizzo sostenibile dei rifiuti
stiamo mettendo più verde ci saranno sei
parchi urbani ma anche una forestazione
del centro storico che ne ha poco
abbiamo trasformato a led tutta
l'illuminazione pubblica stiamo
lavorando su un gemello digitale che con
i dati ci permetterà di pianificare
meglio anche di offrire servizi più
innovativi ai cittadini sul tema
energetico che appunto è quello più
importante stiamo abbiamo Anzi quasi
finito di riqualificare tutte le case
popolari a livello energetico creeremo
comunità energetiche stiamo cambiando le
regole urbanistiche i regolamenti
delizi perché anche i cittadine e le
imprese possano mettere più facilmente
rinnovabili nelle loro imprese e nelle
loro case abbiamo aperto uno sportello
per i cittadini sull'energia per
accompagnarli e stiamo
promuovendo attività di educazione
ambientale energetica climatica
ecologica Insomma tante cose ma come le
stiamo facendo Noi le stanno facendo
anche le società partecipate che sono
tante l'Università di Bologna i centri
nazionali di ricerca che sono basati qua
le imprese grandi piccole Le startup le
cooperative il terzo settore le
associazioni di volontariato la
cittadinanza attiva per esempio col
bilancio partecipativo i patti di
collaborazione abbiamo più di più di
1000 Patti di collaborazione coi
cittadini e speriamo anche la
cittadinanza non ancora attiva insomma
Tutti insieme appassionatamente Ve lo
ricordate Vabbè sono di nuovo avete
capito sono negli anni 60 Do se do
qualcosa te non so Julie Andrews un mio
mito e quindi ecco Tutti insieme
appassionatamente perché in questa
battaglia solo l'unione farà la
forza e bisogna che questo contratto
metta nero su bianco tutti gli
investimenti per iscritto quindi
qualcosa di molto concreto non è un
patto
volante investimenti impegni contributi
azioni di tutti e deve essere un
contratto che in qualche modo rifletta
il DNA della nostra città che è un DNA
di Cooperazione partecipazione
solidarietà diritti ma anche capacità di
innovare capacità di anticipare i tempi
capacità di
cambiare perché i cambiamenti climatici
richiedono cambia menti climatici
dobbiamo cambiare le menti Dobbiamo
cambiare il cuore dobbiamo cambiare i
sentimenti prima si parlava dobbiamo
cambiare i modelli dobbiamo cambiare
tante cose dobbiamo
aumentare consapevole di chi siamo
veramente come esseri terrestri che con
la loro aione appun non solt individuale
mativa di sistema hanno unat sul
benessere di questa terra di questo
pianeta e anche dell'umanità che ci vive
sopra quindi dobbiamo capire questa Anzi
comprendere da cum prendo Prendo in me
con empatia solidarietà per capire
veramente cosa sta succedendo al mondo e
quindi integrare questa necessità di
cambiamento perché penso che questa
missione sia una vera opportunità per
cambiare Bologna per trasformarla in una
città più vivibile più sana più sicura
per i bambini per i più vulnerabili per
riconnetterci con la natura per
ritrovare quell'energia che io ne ho un
gran bisogno quell'energia di cui
appunto abbiamo bisogno per affrontare
questa nuova era quest'era di emergenza
ed è un'occasione per cambiare una cosa
importante quella di rendere più
accessibili le scelte ecologiche che
oggi Se ci pensate bene Non sono ancora
così accessibili a tutti e quindi
combattere la diseguaglianza energetica
e climatica ed è anche un'occasione per
democratizzare ancora di più la città
mettendo al centro le persone in modo
che siano loro a contribuire a questo
processo direttamente lo stiamo vivendo
con l'assemblea cittadina del clima è un
miracolo A proposito e soprattutto
Secondo me può essere un'occasione per
creare delle storie delle storie delle
narrazioni oggi i vecchi saperi non sono
altezza di accompagnarci in questa nuova
fase e non c'è ancora una cultura
alternativa che ci permetta di
fronteggiarla avete cioè non non
l'abbiamo nella nostra quotidianità non
abbiamo delle storie che veramente ci
aiutino a integrarci in questa nuova
fase voi avete mai visto una serie
Netflix su Come si vive in questo in
questo mondo con il con l'azione
climatica e anche le soluzioni che
possiamo vedere le opportunità no ci
sono film che Mh che in qualche modo
fanno vedere l'orrore oppure documentari
ma non c'è una quotidianità come lo è
stato Happy Days se vi ricordate che ha
veramente influenzato
generazioni e infine Secondo me questa è
l'occasione per cambiare la cosa più
importante del mondo unire connettere le
due fini chiave al giorno d'oggi la fine
del mondo con la fine del mese e quindi
veramente promuovere
una transizione giusta Quindi io davvero
io vorrei davvero che Bologna fosse il
luogo da cui partire con questo
cambiamento in cui fare questo viaggio
perché Bologna può essere più potente di
tutti quelli che ancora non credono che
i cambiamenti climatici hanno un impatto
devastante più potente di quelli che
stanno ancora estraendo producendo
distribuendo fonti fossili pur sapendo
quali sono le conseguenze e più potente
dei Signori della Guerra che con le con
le loro armi stanno distruggendo non
solo vite umane ma anche il pianeta
Quindi questa può essere anche una
missione di pace che Bologna sia la
città dell'energia locale dell'energia
umana che davvero ci porti avanti in
questa nuova era e che generi speranza
per le generazioni di oggi e quelle di
domani e per tutte le
Pachito quindi vi ringrazio
dell'attenzione
[Applauso]